saw mom trying to get three kids through
security she just
quitting her eyes just it's a dead look
in her eyes she was just she was kicking
she was
challenging TSA agent she looked like
she wanted to get arrested huh
kicking a bear through the swiper ma'am
you can't huh what who what these yeah
they're mine this one's got a bomb in
her huh he's got a gun she's got a bomb
then we got to go somewhere to her
to a room with a couch take me to that
yeah I'll go take me to the room with
the couch where I can close my eyes for
the first time in 18 calendar months
I think I'll go to the couch room now
huh
how about the couch room
no I did not pack my own bags two brown
men I didn't recognize did that
couch room now
foreign